le bowling club de plaisir l'usine à
champion sur la
piste l'enfant du clubque éev une boule
à la main la championne régionale 2012
la tout prière licen du BCP sur la
pisteéampion des pour une
demisre une activité surprenante surt
pour s
amis pas que ça
spou avec un record à 223 points
Victoria goutorb 17 ans tout juste
affronte déjà les joueurs seniors de
cette réussite sur les pistes dépend
beaucoup la complicité entre le joueur
et sa boule une arme qui devient très
vite le prolongement du bras dès que je
vais au buouling je la prends sinon
j'aime pas aller au bowling 100 parce
que j'y arrive plus à jouer 100 en fait
c'est quoi c'est la superstition un
petit peuou non c'est c'est juste qu'on
a l'habitude et c'est fait à nos doigts
donc c'est sur mesure en fait et
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire la vitesse de la boule et le
Strike ne sont pas l'obsession B le ST
je la sur le gâteau pour
moi le jeu pour les jeunes aujourd'hui
c'est fait les kill en de fois et
d'essayer de faire le maximum de K sur
une première boule le Bing n'est pas un
jeu de force n pas un jeu de rapidité
donc plus vous êtes calme plus vous
allez être précis plus vous aurez de
performance et les 20 jeunes de l'école
de bowling de plaisir semblent avoir
compris cette
philosophie